welcome to this video playing dragon 70
is the head guy that's really high rated
person I can merely accept cuz she on
okay let's see Chad really high rating I
played in one cent no twice won bin one
draw and don't really remember that okay
let's go for a big Center I think 93 is
more precise Oh anyway it's probably not
a big deal yeah exactly this
I can I he can take see for this is kind
of it looks annoying a little bit maybe
Queens affords a move now it's not
really my kind of chess I mean I have
played him twice and I think both times
he had a nice position strategically but
he is a very nice am a very dangerous
tactical player so if a tea group she
had pronotum dropping dropping before I
don't want to do that so this is not the
kind of position that that I like much
against this particular player there are
Nexus 6 30 for the default porn is under
huge pressure
we should be five looks yeah doesn't
look ideal that we threaten night 65 now
or maybe it does but now defaults
protected because the D file is
obstructed see going 45 he or something
I don't know 96 coming
maybe and possibly Bishop c6
and 96 is a bit a bit of an annoyance II
really don't have a good square clearing
d2 okay after night Jake's yeah yeah
okay Bishop c6 he's got 96 and his
covering is covering that that's bad
okay and this is especially bad because
it threatens on youtube no
very bad position yeah that wasn't good
hmm any kind of anything that I can try
here very difficult on got 25 things
like that I mean he has not cancelled so
some nights you five business I cannot
really move anything here this is a big
problem may be Queen d3 just win I don't
know just don't want to resign now and
see if I can okay I yes yes can I can
just cancel you can just cancel and I'm
taking you five then I canceling still
does win SB one is hanging Ruby one is
also probably winning
nairobi one is a simple win actually I
can check him here yeah I can do this
can give this chicks check but king of
six as possible is really nothing
happening check
check check check
check two they haven't you unfortunately
as long as this king is slightly exposed
I'm not resigning him but probably there
is nothing nothing really i'm not even
threatening a check IAM even Queen III
or something should should win yeah
basically or moves win
well he will not take at allow Quincy
six I guess and maybe I can irritate him
still a little bit look if we would have
gone g6 it would have been a bit easier
but ok it's still still black wins of
course
g6 is still possible check yeah that's
also a good move
my takes a 350 k white resigns they are
screwed up the opening already this is
this is already kind of difficult okay i
can go away three but this is not very
ambitious so i went here and maybe this
isn't a good idea that that pawn on d4
is somewhat problematic they played that
played that well here i'm struggling
really the engine wants to play
differently and now all kinds of people
beggar why is jeiza no 411 backing
things up who the heck is GJ 0 for 11
okay um how do i how do i stop that okay
give me a give me a new board and i'm
going to open up open up this and then
see what happens okay so yeah probably
this is too ambitious and here i'm
really in slide trouble let me check age
5 and this is all all right yeah the
compounds to do this
yeah I wasn't really sure what to do now
an engine wants to play like this now
and give up that poem there's already a
bit screwed up really position is just
too bad you're not coming back from that
yeah I didn't see that one but it's
already basically lost him a two way sir
is a threat end I mean if antique yeah
even 90 x I just it just totally rotten
I could have resided here but somehow I
didn't want you can check check check
check yeah okay that's really a lost
cause yeah I dwellest avoids I mean it's
a playable move it's not terribly bad
but for example I can if I'm really like
out of ideas I can of course Teague and
develop or so and it's equal but it's
not really a very ambitious i wanted to
i really i would want to do this this is
more interesting the dye ideas if black
now plays Knight f6 you can actually
think about playing e4 because this
mission TX 94 Queen g4s actually quite
interesting this is some what I wanted
where I wanted to go I would I I really
i played this a bit too hasty to hastily
and now d 5 is coming there's also
difference by the way to Queen e7 after
Queen e7 sorry instead of a five then e
4 is a different story because now after
d 5v5 widest impact in good shape
because now the queen is not putting any
pressure on their porn I was basically
confusing the two lines him and its
really led into big trouble already okay
thanks for watching